It is painful to grasp, but mass shootings have become a common occurrence in the United States. Whether at a school, a church, or synagogue, or a supermarket, these incidents may shock, but they no longer surprise. Cities, small towns, and schools across the country are now associated forever with this form of violence, names like Columbine, Sandy Hook, Parkland, and Uvaldi, Aurora, Charleston, Boulder, and Buffalo. Each time politicians spar over whether to blame guns, mental illness, or moral decay for the massacres. Against this backdrop, it's easy to feel hopeless and to think that mass shootings have simply become an unavoidable part of American life. But according to some researchers, there is hope. By studying what drives mass shooters, they say, we can better understand the causes of America's mass shooting epidemic and perhaps learn how to stop it.
这很难接受，但大规模枪击事件在美国已屡见不鲜。无论发生在学校、教堂、犹太会堂还是超级市场，这些事件或许令人震惊，但已不再让人意外。全国各地的城市、小镇和学校如今都永远与这种形式的暴力联系在一起，科伦拜恩、桑迪胡克、帕克兰、尤瓦尔迪、奥罗拉、查尔斯顿、博尔德和布法罗等名字便是明证。每次惨剧发生后，政客们都会争论究竟该将枪支、精神疾病还是道德沦丧归咎于此。在此背景下，人们很容易感到绝望，认为大规模枪击事件已然成为美国生活中不可避免的一部分。但一些研究人员表示，希望依然存在。他们说，通过研究枪击者的动机，我们可以更好地了解美国大规模枪击事件频发的根源，或许还能找到制止这种现象的方法。
What drives most mass shooters? What do they have in common? What role, if any, does mental illness play in their actions? What about racist and extremist ideologies? What about the internet? Does media coverage of mass shootings drive copycat crimes? Do active shooter drills and armed guards at schools save lives? And what can be done in workplaces, houses of worship, and other venues to make the next mass shooting less likely? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Gillian Peterson, a psychologist and associate professor of criminology and criminal justice at Hamline University in St. Paul, Minnesota. She is a co-founder of the Violence Project, a nonprofit organization that has compiled
是什么驱使了大多数枪击者？他们有什么共同点？精神疾病在他们的行径中扮演了什么角色（如果有的话）？种族主义和极端主义意识形态呢？互联网呢？媒体对大规模枪击事件的报道会助长模仿犯罪吗？学校的应急演练和武装警卫能挽救生命吗？在工作场所、礼拜场所和其他地方，可以采取哪些措施来降低下一次大规模枪击事件发生的可能性？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，主要探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是吉莉安·彼得森博士，她是一名心理学家，也是明尼苏达州圣保罗市哈姆林大学犯罪学与刑事司法副教授。她是“暴力项目”（Violence Project）的联合创始人，该非营利组织整理了
the database of every mass shooting in the U.S. since 2016. She and her colleagues have also interviewed friends, family, victims, and in some cases, the perpetrators themselves, to compile detailed life histories of some 180 mass shooters. The goal of the Violence Project is to use this information to better understand mass shooters' pathways to violence and develop strategies to stop them. Dr. Peterson's book, The Violence Project, How to Stop a Mass Shooting epidemic, co-authored with her colleagues, colleague Dr. James Densley, was published in 2021. Thank you for joining me today, Dr. Peterson.
自2016年以来美国历次大规模枪击事件的数据库。她和同事还采访了亲友、受害者，在某些情况下甚至采访了凶手本人，从而整理出大约180名大规模枪击者的详细生平。暴力项目的目标是利用这些信息更好地了解枪击者走向暴力的轨迹，并制定阻止他们的策略。彼得森博士与其同事詹姆斯·丹斯利博士合著的《暴力项目：如何阻止大规模枪击流行病》一书于2021年出版。非常感谢您今天能参加我们的节目，彼得森博士。
Thank you so much for having me. I'm happy to be here. So I just mentioned that the Violence Project has compiled a database of every mass shooting in the United States since 1966. So first, how did you define mass shooting? Because not everyone who counts these incidents defines mass shooting in the same way. Yeah, it's an important question because depending on how, how you define a mass shooting, you can say there's been five or six in the past year or hundreds. So we use a pretty narrow definition, which is four or more people killed in a public space, not including the perpetrator, and the shooting is not related to other underlying criminal activity,
非常感谢邀请我来。我很高兴能来到这里。我刚才提到，“暴力项目”整理了自1966年以来美国每一次大规模枪击事件的数据库。首先，你们是如何定义大规模枪击事件的？因为并非所有统计这些事件的人对大规模枪击的定义都一样。是的，这是一个重要问题，因为根据你对大规模枪击的定义，你可以说过去一年发生了五六起，或者数百起。因此，我们使用的是一个相当狭窄的定义，即在公共空间内有四人或四人以上被杀害，不包括作案者在内，且枪击事件与其它潜在的犯罪活动无关，
and it's not a domestic violence situation. So many of us have the impression that mass shootings are on the increase in the United States. Is that borne out by the data you've been collecting? It is. So we're tracking these incidents where four more people have been killed. And we see that the worst incidents on record were 2017, 2018, 2019. Those were the worst years. Then we had this pause during the pandemic because public spaces weren't open.
并且它不是家庭暴力情况。因此，我们许多人都有这样一种印象：美国的大规模枪击事件正在增加。你们收集的数据证实了这一点吗？确实如此。我们一直在追踪那些造成四人或更多人死亡的事件。我们发现，有记录以来最糟糕的事件发生在2017年、2018年和2019年。那是情况最糟糕的几年。然后，我们在大流行期间经历了一段停滞期，因为公共空间没有开放。
And when we did reopen in 2020, 2021, we've seen this kind of resurgence, especially this summer. had one of the worst sort of month or two on record in terms of mass shootings. What do you attribute this increase to? It's hard to say exactly. I think it's a number of factors at play. One is that during the pandemic, a number of risk factors for mass shootings, we know increased. So things like isolation, hopelessness, spending increasing amounts of time online, suicidality. We also had record gun sales in this country. So there's just more access to firearms. And what have you learned about the profile of the people who commit mass shootings? What do these men,
当我们于2020年和2021年重新开放时，我们看到了这种卷土重来的趋势，尤其是今年夏天。就大规模枪击事件而言，我们经历了有记录以来最糟糕的一两个月之一。您将这种增长归因于什么？这很难确切说明。我认为有多个因素在起作用。其一是，我们知道在大流行期间，大规模枪击事件的许多风险因素增加了。比如孤立感、绝望感、花在网上的时间越来越多、自杀倾向。这个国家的枪支销量也创下了历史新高。因此，人们接触枪支的机会更多了。关于犯下大规模枪击事件的人的个人资料，你们了解到了什么？这些男性——
and they are mostly men, have in common? Yes. So in our database, it's 98% men. There's four women in the database. Two of them perpetrated the shooting with a man. So we see this common pathway. And of course, it's a little different for each person. But this pathway seems to start with really significant early childhood trauma. So things like physical abuse, sexual abuse, suicide of a parent, domestic violence in the home. Over time, that individual becomes angry, becomes isolated, becomes hopeless. There's a lot of self-loathing there. Many of them are suicidal, an attempt suicide before doing a mass shooting. then that self-loathing kind of turns outward and it becomes whose fault is this? Who do I blame
而且他们绝大多数是男性——有什么共同点？是的。在我们的数据库中，98%是男性。数据库中有四名女性。其中两名女性是与一名男性共同作案的。因此，我们看到了这种共同的轨迹。当然，对每个人来说都略有不同。但这轨迹似乎始于非常严重的早期童年创伤。比如身体虐待、性虐待、父母自杀、家里的家庭暴力。随着时间的推移，这个人会变得愤怒、孤立、绝望。其中包含着大量的自我厌恶。许多人都有自杀倾向，在实施大规模枪击之前曾尝试过自杀。然后这种自我厌恶便转向外部，变成了“这是谁的错？我该怪谁”
for the fact that I feel this way? So school shooters blame their school. Workplace shooters blame their workplace. Other people blame, you know, religious groups or racial groups or women. Perpetrators tend to be radicalized through studying other shooters before them. Many of them spend time on the internet and kind of these dark chat rooms where violence is really celebrated and validated. And then they go into this act knowing it's their final act. So they're kind of actively suicidal planning to die in the act. They have access to the firearms that they need. And many of them leak their plans.
“怪我为什么会有这种感觉？”因此，学校枪击者怪他们的学校。工作场所枪击者怪他们的工作场所。其他人则怪宗教群体、种族群体或女性。凶手往往是通过研究他们之前的其他枪击者而被激进化的。许多人花时间在互联网和这些宣扬并认可暴力的黑暗聊天室里。接着，他们抱着这是最后一次行动的心态实施犯罪。因此，他们实际上有自杀倾向，计划在行动中死去。他们获得了所需的枪支。许多人还泄露了他们的计划。
Many of them tell other people they're thinking about violence before they do it. And then they go out and they choose a location that's symbolic of their grievance with the world because they're looking for this fame and notoriety in their death that they didn't have in their life. What role, if any, does mental illness play in mass shootings? We always hear from local leaders, politicians, law enforcement that whoever perpetrated a mass shooting must be mentally ill. Is that always the case? It's not. And this is one of the initial questions that kind of got me into this research, because before mass shootings, I studied the link between mental illness and crime and violence, and it was something that we always turned to instinctually.
许多人在付诸行动之前会告诉其他人他们有暴力倾向。然后他们走出去，选择一个象征着他们对世界不满的地点，因为他们希望在死亡中获得生前未曾拥有的名誉和名气。精神疾病在大规模枪击事件中起到了什么作用（如果有的话）？我们总是听到地方领导人、政客、执法人员说，无论谁实施了大规模枪击，一定都有精神疾病。事实总是如此吗？并非如此。这也是最初让我开始这项研究的问题之一，因为在大规模枪击事件之前，我研究的是精神疾病与犯罪和暴力之间的联系，这是我们总是凭直觉想到的事情。
It's like we don't understand this, so somebody must be mentally ill. So we looked really deeply at histories of mental illness, at diagnoses, at previous counseling, psychiatric medication, anything that we could find. So we did find most mass shooters, about two-thirds, have some sort of mental health history. That being said, there was no one diagnosis. that was consistent over time. Thought disorders were overrepresented compared to the general population. But when we tried to look at what role does psychosis play in leading to a mass shooting, it was about 10% of perpetrators. We could say psychosis really was an active role here,
就像我们不理解这一点，所以某人一定有精神疾病。因此，我们深入研究了精神疾病史、诊断结果、先前的心理咨询、精神科药物，以及我们能找到的任何东西。我们确实发现大多数大规模枪击者（大约三分之二）都有某种心理健康病史。话虽如此，并没有哪一种诊断结果随时间推移而保持一致。与普通人口相比，思维障碍的比例过高。但当我们试图探究精神病在导致大规模枪击事件中起了什么作用时，大约占凶手的10%。我们可以说精神病在这里确实起到了积极作用，
whereas the other 90% it's much more complicated. So even perpetrators who did have a history of mental illness, it's like it's this complex build, this complex pathway. way to violence. And mental illness is not typically the thing that is pushing them over the edge. We see that perpetrators are in crisis before the shooting. That might be related to mental illness. It might be not. We see that they're suicidal. But trying to sort of pick out a diagnosis and say this is what these perpetrators have in common. You absolutely can't do that. Do we know enough at this point to predict who might become a mass shooter? I know APA did a study a number of years ago. there's very limited information back then. There's maybe a little bit more today. But we were not
而在其他90%的情况下，情况要复杂得多。因此，即使是确实有精神病史的凶手，这也是一种复杂的积累，是一条复杂的通往暴力的道路。精神疾病通常并不是将他们推向边缘的因素。我们发现凶手在枪击发生前都处于危机之中。这可能与精神疾病有关，也可能无关。我们发现他们有自杀倾向。但是，试图挑出某种诊断并说这就是这些凶手共同拥有的特征，这是绝对做不到的。就目前而言，我们对预测谁可能成为大规模枪击者有足够的了解吗？我知道美国心理学协会多年前做过一项研究。当时的信息非常有限。今天可能稍微多了一点。但我们没能
able to come up with any kind of a guideline for this person has these five factors and therefore given the opportunity is going to go kill a bunch of people. Yeah, no, we're not able to do that because for each person who has those five factors, you know, 99.99% of them would never do this. And so it really is like finding a needle in a haystack. What we do know is that, perpetrators who do this tend to tell other people that they're thinking about it, tend to talk about violence, school shooters. It's about 80% of them tell their classmates that they're planning on it. So we know there's these warning signs.
得出任何指导方针，能够判定这个人有这五个因素，因此只要有机会就会去杀害一群人。是的，不，我们无法做到这一点，因为对于拥有这五个因素的每个人来说，你知道，其中99.99%的人永远不会这样做。所以这真的就像大海捞针。我们所知道的是，实施这一行为的凶手往往会告诉其他人他们有这种想法，往往会谈论暴力，学校枪击者中，大约80%的人会告诉同班同学他们正计划这样做。所以我们知道这些警示信号是存在的。
We know they're actively suicidal in crisis. Behavior is changing. And so what we advocate for is building systems in schools and organizations that can watch for this type of behavior, for this leakage, for kids in crisis, provide them with resources, not because we think, oh, here's the next school. shooter, but it's here's somebody in crisis who needs some intervention. And that might prevent a school shooting. It might prevent a whole lot of things, though. There's kind of this diffusion of benefit to these systems where you're preventing suicides, you're preventing violence. But there's
我们知道他们正处于危机的自杀状态中。行为正在发生变化。因此，我们主张在学校和机构中建立能够关注这种类型行为、关注这种泄露、关注处于危机中的孩子的系统，为他们提供资源，不是因为我们认为“哦，看，这就是下一个学校枪击者”，而是因为“这是一个需要干预的处于危机中的人”。这可能会阻止一起学校枪击事件。不过，这可能还会阻止很多其他事情。这些系统具有某种效益扩散效应，你可以借此预防自杀、预防暴力。但
no way I can give you, here's the 20 things. And if you check these boxes, here's your school shooter. So you mentioned leakage in schools in particular where shooters may be letting people know that they're planning something. And it's in schools, you know, we're very focused. on either these active shooter drills or whether they want to bring in armed guards or other people who might somehow prevent this. But wouldn't it make more sense to be training the children how to recognize these factors and then what to do in the event that they see something and then they should say something to whom do they say it? Are we doing that? Not really yet. I don't think we are quite there yet. I think for a long time, really, so post-Columbine,
我没有办法给你列出“这20件事是什么，只要你勾选了这些选项，这就是你的学校枪击者”。所以你提到了学校里的信息泄露，特别是枪击者可能会让别人知道他们在计划什么。而在学校里，你知道，我们非常专注于这些应急演练，或者考虑是否要引入武装警卫或其他可能以某种方式阻止这种情况的人。但是，教导孩子们如何识别这些因素，然后在看到某些情况时知道该做什么，并向某人举报，难道不是更有意义吗？他们应该向谁举报呢？我们在这样做吗？其实还没有。我认为我们还没有完全做到这一点。我认为长期以来，也就是科伦拜恩事件之后，
It's been about reducing casualties, right? How do we send our kids in bulletproof backpacks and make these fancy security systems and these strong doors and active shooter training? That was all based on this premise that the person doing the shooting was not a child in the building. Right. We now know that 90% of the time it's a current or former student. This is a kid sitting next to our kid in class, walking in and out of the security and running through all the drills. This is a child who's an insider, not an outsider. And that really shifts your perspective about how we prevent this. In some ways, it's harder because it's not a kid you can keep out with security. It's a kid coming to school every day. But in some ways, it's easier because we can look out for these warning signs. We can do things like build really strong, trusting relationships between kids and adults in the building. So kids feel safe disclosing things. And a lot of times kids don't disclose things because we have this really punitive response. You know, They're not going to tell on their friend and get their friend kicked out of school or their friend criminally charged and sent to prison.
重点一直放在减少伤亡上，对吧？我们如何让孩子背上防弹背包，建造这些精美的安保系统、坚固的门以及进行应急演练？这一切都基于这样一个前提：开枪的人不是大楼里的孩子。对吧。我们现在知道，90%的情况下，凶手是现任或前任学生。这是一个坐在班里我们孩子旁边、穿梭于安保之中并经历所有演练的孩子。这是一个内部人员，而不是外部人员。这确实改变了你对我们如何预防这种情况的看法。在某些方面，这更难，因为这不是一个你可以靠安保挡在门外的孩子；这是一个每天都来上学的孩子。但在某些方面，这更容易，因为我们可以留意这些警示信号。我们可以做一些事情，比如在大楼里的孩子和成年人之间建立非常牢固、信任的关系，让孩子们感到公开倾诉是安全的。很多时候，孩子们不肯倾诉，是因为我们有非常严厉的惩罚性反应。你知道，
But they might report their friend if their response is kind of compassionate. It's about care. It's about connecting to resources. So quite a few of the recent shootings have targeted black Americans or Asian Americans, Jews, other minority groups. What percentage of mass shootings involve racist or extremist ideology? You know, that's not a number of the top of my head. It's actually a minority of them. We have seen an increase in hate-driven mass shootings where there is a specific hateful ideology associated with it. What we're interested in is kind of how do people get to that
他们不会告发自己的朋友，让朋友被开除出校或受到刑事指控并送进监狱。但如果回应是带有同情心的，是关乎关怀和资源对接的，他们可能会举报自己的朋友。因此，最近的一些枪击事件有不少将黑人、亚裔、犹太人或其他少数群体作为目标。有多少比例的大规模枪击事件涉及种族主义或极端主义意识形态？你知道，这不是一个我能脱口而出的数字。实际上，这只是其中的一小部分。我们确实看到仇恨驱动的大规模枪击事件有所增加，其中存在与之相关的特定仇恨意识形态。我们感兴趣的是，人们是如何走向那种
hateful ideology? And one thing that we found is that hate actually comes relatively late upon the pathway to violence. It's like they are in crisis, they're suicidal, they're self-loathing, they're angry at the world, and then they find this thing to blame that they now hate. And sometimes they find it because they stumble onto a website, but these are not, you know, young people being raised in households full of racist ideology. Sometimes they stumble onto it a month or two months before the shooting, and they couldn't even really tell you a lot of details about it. But it's they glom onto this thing. And I think it's really important that we tackle that hate, especially, I think, when we can talk about social media and where young people
充满仇恨的意识形态的？我们发现的一点是，仇恨实际上相对较晚地出现在通往暴力的道路上。就像他们处于危机中、有自杀倾向、自我厌恶、对世界愤怒，然后他们找到了一个可以怪罪的目标，从而开始恨它。有时他们找到这个目标是因为偶然 stumbled onto 一个网站，但这些并不是在充满种族主义意识形态的家庭中抚养长大的年轻人。有时他们在枪击发生前一个月或两个月偶然接触到这些，甚至无法向你详细讲述很多细节。但他们就是死死抓住这一点不放。我认为我们必须打击这种仇恨，尤其是当我们谈论社交媒体以及年轻人从哪里
are getting access to this type of hate online. But it's also important to look at what's underlying that so we can prevent people from getting to that point. And so it's sort of both of those pieces. So we talked a minute ago about how most of the mass shooters you've identified are male. Most of them are also white males. And I'm just wondering how much a sense of disenfranchise is playing a role here, whether it's, you know, feminism has ruined my life or that black guy took my job or just these feelings of the world is now unfair to white men. Is that a factor that you see? It is a factor. I think it's a really hard factor to measure, right? But we can, we talk about it in the book. We have a chapter called America. And we can talk about guns in America and we can talk about
在网上获取这种类型的仇恨时，这一点非常重要。但审视其背后的根源同样重要，这样我们才能阻止人们走到那一步。所以这两部分都很重要。我们刚才讨论了你确定的大多数大规模枪击者都是男性。他们大多也是白人男性。我只是想知道，剥夺感在这里起了多大作用，无论是“女性主义毁了我的生活”、“那个黑人抢了我的工作”，还是仅仅觉得这个世界现在对白人群体不公平。这是你看到的一个因素吗？这是一个因素。我认为这是一个很难衡量的因素，对吧？但我们可以，我们在书中讨论过它。我们有一个章节叫“美国”。我们可以谈论美国的枪支，也可以谈论
violence in America. But there's also this other piece here that I think is about disenfranchised white men. And there's this piece that we see in these perpetrators where it's like, I was owed this thing. I expected to be in this place in my life where I'm not, right? The world owes me success or owes me a girlfriend or owes me a job or owes me whatever. That I think when you don't get that, then somehow you're angrier and it must be someone's fault. I do think that level of kind of entitlement is a big piece of this that goes along with being a white man. A lot of other people don't expect that. They don't feel that they're owed. And so I do think we do see that. But again, it's hard to really measure and grasp. Are there similar patterns among the rare people
美国的暴力。但这里还有另外一部分，我认为它关乎被剥夺权利的白人男性。我们在这些凶手身上看到了这样一部分心理，即“我本该得到这个”。我期望自己处于生活中不曾达到的那个位置，对吧？世界欠我成功，或者欠我一个女朋友，或者欠我一份工作，或者欠我别的什么。我认为，当你没有得到这些时，你会变得更加愤怒，这一定是谁的错。我确实认为这种程度的权利意识是其中的一个重要部分，它伴随着成为一个白人男性的身份而存在。许多其他人并不期待这一点。他们不觉得自己被亏欠了。所以我确实认为我们看到了这一点。但再次强调，这很难真正衡量和理解。在你发现的那些罕见的
of color you have found who do commit mass shootings? Yeah, you do see. So perpetrators are majority white, but it's only around 60% white. So you do see perpetrators of color. You see a lot more workplace shootings perpetrated by men of color. A lot of times it's somebody, so they tend to be kind of factories, warehouses. They tend to be in the south, kind of the primary employer of the town. And it's typically somebody who just got fired. And so they lose their identity.
有色人种大规模枪击者身上，是否存在类似的标准？是的，你确实会看到。所以凶手大多数是白人，但白人比例大约只占60%左右。所以你确实会看到有色人种凶手。你会看到更多由有色人种男性实施的工作场所枪击事件。很多时候是某个人，所以他们往往是在工厂、仓库。他们往往位于南方，往往是该城镇的主要雇主。这通常是刚刚被解雇的人。因此他们失去了身份认同。
They lose their, you know, resources. they lose social services, all the things that we tie to employment. Somebody who just got fired is pushed over the edge. And oftentimes it's not that well planned. It's like they go to their car and pull their handgun that they legally own out of their glove box and go back in and commit a mass shooting. Those have actually gone down in recent years. We see a lot more of those in kind of 80, 90s, early 2000s.
他们失去了资源，失去了社会服务，失去了我们与就业挂钩的所有东西。一个刚被解雇的人被逼到了绝境。而且通常这并没有经过很好的策划。就像他们走到车前，从手套箱里拿出自己合法拥有的手枪，然后走回去实施大规模枪击。这类事件近年 faktisk 实际上有所下降。我们在80年代、90年代和2000年代初期看到了更多这类事件。
You've written about social contagion. People who are at risk of committing violent acts. They see news stories about a shooting and are spurred to go out and do the same thing. Are there ways that the media could cover these events differently to lessen the likelihood of copycat shootings? There is. Yes. There's this wonderful organization called No Notaryity, which was founded by Tom and Karen Tees, who lost their son. He was killed in the O'Rourke, Colorado shooting. And they were really appalled with the level of coverage that that perpetrator received in the media. His face was everywhere, all over cable news on the front of newspapers and magazines, where their son, just kind of faded away and didn't get that same type of attention. And we do know that perpetrators are looking for that attention. We call these a type of performance crimes because they are meant to be watched and witnessed. They're meant to create fear. They're meant to have their manifesto go viral.
你写过关于社会传染的内容。面临暴力行为风险的人。他们看到关于枪击事件的新闻报道，便受到刺激走出去做出同样的事情。媒体可以通过不同的方式报道这些事件，以减少模仿性枪击发生的可能性吗？可以的。是的。有一个非常棒的组织叫“拒绝恶名”（No Notoriety），由汤姆和凯伦·蒂斯创立，他们的儿子在科罗拉多州奥罗拉枪击事件中遇害。他们对媒体对该凶手报道的程度感到非常震惊。他的面孔无处不在，充斥着有线新闻、报纸和杂志的头版，而他们的儿子却只是渐渐被人遗忘，没有得到同等程度的关注。我们确实知道，凶手正在寻求这种关注。我们将这些称为表演型犯罪，因为它们旨在被观看和目击。它们旨在制造恐惧。它们旨在让自己的宣言在网络上广为流传。
They're meant to have their name make the history books alongside all these other names. And so there's this piece of this that when we watch and when we consume it, we're kind of giving them the attention that they're looking for, and then also inspiring the next person looking for that same level of attention. So the no notoriety protocol is focused. It's similar to actually the way that media covers suicides, because we know celebrity suicides, there's a contagion aspect to that. And so now journalists are trained in how to cover suicides in a way to not give details about how the suicide was committed to kind of minimize coverage so is not to amplify that contagion. It's similar for mass shootings. We can talk about the mass shooting. We can talk about the victims, the first responders,
它们旨在将自己的名字与所有这些其他名字一起载入历史书籍。因此，当我们观看和消费这些内容时，我们在某种程度上正是在给予他们所寻求的关注，同时也激励了下一个寻求同等程度关注的人。因此，“拒绝恶名”协议的重点在于，这实际上类似于媒体报道自库的方式，因为我们知道名人自杀存在传染效应。因此，现在的记者接受了如何报道自杀的培训，即不透露自杀是如何进行的细节，以尽量减少报道，从而不放大这种传染效应。大规模枪击事件也是如此。我们可以谈论大规模枪击事件。我们可以谈论受害者、第一响应者，
but not to give the perpetrator that level of attention that they're looking for. For a significant number of mass shooters, the act is a way to end their lives. I mean, you've said that they're either going to be killed by law enforcement officers or they may end up shooting themselves. Is there a way to use some of the suicide prevention strategies that psychology has developed to reduce the number of mass shootings? I really think that there is. This was a real kind of eye-opening moment for me. We interviewed a number of perpetrators.
但不要给予凶手他们所寻求的那种程度的关注。对于相当一部分大规模枪击者来说，这种行为是他们结束生命的一种方式。我的意思是，你说过他们要么会被执法人员击毙，要么最终会开枪自杀。有没有办法利用心理学发展的一些自杀预防策略来减少大规模枪击事件的数量？我真的认为可以。这对我来说是一个真正大开眼界的时刻。我们采访了多名凶手。
This was consistently they said that they went in to be killed by police or they went in planning to kill themselves. The number of perpetrators who attempted suicide beforehand was astounding. And we realized nobody goes in planning to come out. There's no like put on a disguise and race for the border. It's you go in. You have to be caught for this in order to get the attention that you want. So you have to either be killed, kill yourself, or spend the rest of your life in prison. It's a final act. And for me, who I have a background in suicide prevention before this, I was like, oh, these are suicides, right? In addition to being
他们一致表示，他们进去就是为了被警察杀死，或者他们进去就计划自杀。曾试图自杀的凶手数量惊人。我们意识到，没有人会计划活着出来。没有什么“化装成别的样子然后向边境狂奔”的事。你走进去。为了获得你想要的关注，你必须为此被捕。所以你要么被杀，要么自杀，要么在监狱里度过余生。这是最后一步。对我这个有自杀预防背景的人来说，我想，哦，这些就是自杀，对吧？除了是
homicides, suicide, we know how to prevent suicide. There's a ton of wonderful research about suicide prevention and strategies that we can use, but we're not using it here because we're not thinking of them like that. We're thinking of them as these horrific homicides that they are. But when we think about homicide, we think about things like deterrence and armed officers and all these things that won't work if the person is going in planning to die in the act. And so it really shifts your thinking and simple things like giving schools and organizations more suicide prevention resources in suicide prevention training could be really helpful here. It seems like one simple answer is to stop the proliferation of guns.
凶杀之外，自杀，我们知道如何预防自杀。有很多关于自杀预防的精彩研究以及我们可以使用的策略，但我们在这里没有使用它们，因为我们没有把他们看作是那样的人。我们把他们看作是他们所是的那些可怕的凶杀案制造者。但当我们想到凶杀时，我们会想到威慑、武装警卫和所有这些事情，如果这个人是抱着在行动中死去的计划进去的，这些就不会起作用。所以这确实改变了你的思维方式，一些简单的事情，比如给学校和机构提供更多的自杀预防资源和自杀预防培训，在这里可能会非常有用。一个简单的答案似乎是制止枪支的泛滥。
I mean, I know everybody says that guns kill people. And we, well, I mean, people kill people. Guns could kill people. People with guns kill people. But, I mean, what are the policy changes that could be made in our current environment that would help stem the prevalence of these mass shootings. Yeah, gun policy is something we looked really closely at. We actually built a gun database in addition to the mass shooter database.
我的意思是，我知道每个人都说枪杀人。我们，好吧，我的意思是，人杀人。枪可能杀人。带着枪的人杀人。但是，我的意思是，在我们当前的环境中，可以做出哪些政策改变来帮助遏制这些大规模枪击事件的蔓延？是的，枪支政策是我们密切研究过的一个问题。除了大规模枪击数据库外，我们实际上还建立了一个枪支数据库。
So we coded every gun used in every mass shooting. So it's four or five hundred guns. And we coded how they were obtained, when they were obtained, legally, illegally. If they were changed, you're modified, to really try to add data to our conversations around gun violence prevention. So we could say, you know, safe storage would have prevented this many people from dying or a red flag law would have prevented this many people from dying. So what the data shows is when it comes to school shooters,
因此，我们对每次大规模枪击事件中使用的每一把枪进行了编码，总共有四五百把枪。我们对它们的获取方式、获取时间、合法性或非法性进行了编码。如果它们被改装或修改过，我们都在尝试为围绕枪支暴力预防的对话添加数据。这样我们就可以说，你知道，安全存放本可以挽救这么多人，或者红旗法案本可以挽救这么多人。因此，数据显示，当谈到学校枪击者时，
they are all taking their parents' guns or their grandparents' guns because they can't typically afford or they can't legally buy them because they're kids of that school and they're not 18. So safe storage campaigns can be really important there. These are guns that are in the home that are unsecured. that young people in crisis have access to. That's something that's got pretty universal support, actually, from gun owners and non-gun owners alike.
他们都是拿父母或祖父母的枪，因为他们通常买不起，或者因为他们是该校的孩子且未满18岁而无法合法购买。因此，安全存放宣传活动在那方面非常重要。这些是家里的枪支，存放得并不安全。处于危机中的年轻人可以接触到这些枪支。实际上，枪支拥有者和非枪支拥有者对此类事情有着相当普遍的支持。
Our data would support red flag laws or extreme risk protection orders because we know that so many of these perpetrators are in crisis, are leaking their plans, are suicidal. So those are laws that allow for guns to be temporarily removed from somebody's possession if they are in danger to sell for others. There's tricky parts about implementing those laws that I think we're still figuring out, but our data would support them. And then any way we can slow down somebody purchasing a gun when they're in crisis.
我们的数据支持红旗法案或极端风险保护令，因为我们知道许多这样的凶手都处于危机之中，正在泄露他们的计划，并有自杀倾向。因此，这些法律允许在某人对自己或他人构成危险时，暂时将其拥有的枪支收缴。实施这些法律有一些棘手的部分，我认为我们仍在摸索中，但我们的数据支持它们。然后，任何可以减缓处于危机中的人购买枪支速度的方法。
So over the summer, we saw a lot of young men on their 18th birthday going out and buying an AR-15. So anything where we can raise the minimum age, where we can create waiting periods or permit to purchase, It's about slowing that down. So you're not able to go out when you're in a state of crisis, immediately purchase a firearm and go commit a shooting. What about the way that gun manufacturers are marketing? I mean, it seems to me that there is a lot of push toward hyper-masculine feeling,
所以在夏天，我们看到许多年轻人在他们18岁生日那天出去购买AR-15。因此，任何可以提高最低年龄、可以建立等待期或购买许可的地方，其核心都在于放慢速度。这样你在处于危机状态时，就无法立即购买枪支并去实施枪击。枪支制造商的营销方式呢？我的意思是，在我看来，有很多朝着超级男性化感觉推进的趋势，
like you need this big gun because it's going to prove that you're a big man. I mean, what can be done about that? Yeah, it's an interesting question that we haven't looked too much into. So what we do know is that assault weapons are really overrepresented in mass shootings. So in kind of everyday homicide, it's about 1% of shootings are involving an assault weapon. In mass shootings, it's closer to 25%. And that's been increasing over time. I think we might actually be up to like 28 or 29% now.
就像你需要这把大枪一样，因为它会证明你是一个男子汉。我的意思是，对此可以做些什么？是的，这是一个有趣的问题，我们还没有对此进行太多深入研究。所以我们知道的是，突击武器在大规模枪击事件中被严重过度代表。在日常凶杀案中，大约1%的枪击事件涉及突击武器。而在大规模枪击事件中，这一比例接近25%。而且这一比例随着时间的推移一直在增加。我认为我们现在的比例实际上可能已经上升到28%或29%左右了。
They really are used much more frequently. Part of that is because you can kill more people faster. And a lot of these perpetrators, their goal is to kill as many people as possible to make the biggest headlines. But the other piece of this is there's this sort of ritual around what a mass shooter does, right, and what they look like and what they dress like, and they study each other and they mimic each other. And so I think this assault weapon, AR-15 in particular, but it's become this symbol, right? It has this symbolic value that's kind of great, even greater than the damage that it can do. And so I think mass shooters are drawn to it in that way as well.
它们确实被更频繁地使用。部分原因是你可以更快地杀死更多人。许多这样的凶手的目标是杀死尽可能多的人，以制造最大的新闻头条。但这一问题的另一个方面是，大规模枪击者的行为、他们的外表、他们的穿着都存在某种仪式感，他们互相研究、互相模仿。因此，我认为这种突击武器，特别是AR-15，已经成为了一个符号，对吧？它具有一种象征价值，甚至比它能造成的破坏本身还要巨大。因此，我认为大规模枪击者也正是以这种方式被它吸引的。
I don't know if that's marketing or just that social contagion piece of this. But thinking about how do we stop that, I think in particular laws limiting access to assault weapons, especially for 18 and 19-year-old young men in crisis, are really critical. Are there any other patterns that I have missed asking you about? Is there like any kind of a geographic pattern that we see to where mass shootings happen? They happen everywhere. They are most common in the south and in the west, although West is primarily from the state of California has a lot of mass shootings. They're a heavily populated state, but they also have a lot of fame-seeking mass shootings, which is interesting.
我不知道这到底是营销行为，还是仅仅是社会传染的一部分。但考虑到我们如何阻止这种情况，我认为限制获取突击武器的法律，特别是针对处于危机中的18、19岁年轻男性的法律，至关重要。我还有什么关于其他模式的问题漏掉了吗？比如我们看到大规模枪击事件发生的地点有什么地理模式吗？它们无处不在。它们在南部和西部最为常见，尽管西部主要来自加利福尼亚州，该州发生了很多大规模枪击事件。这是一个人口稠密的州，但他们也有很多寻求名誉的大规模枪击事件，这很有趣。
School shootings you see occur typically at very large suburban or rural public high schools. I think, you know, we can't say exactly why that is. But theoretically, I think it's about that feeling of not being seen, right? Like not having people notice you or pay attention to you, it's just a lot easier to not be seen in these really big high schools. These are young men who typically have really no one that they're connecting with. We do have kind of a communities database that, and so all of this, by the way, you can download. for free and analyze and, you know, play with. And it's been downloaded thousands of times by researchers and journalists and policy makers.
学校枪击事件通常发生在非常大的郊区或农村公立高中。我想，你知道，我们不能确切地说为什么会这样。但从理论上讲，我认为这关乎那种没有被看见的感觉，对吧？就像没有人注意到你或关注你一样，在这些非常大的高中里，不被看见要容易得多。这些通常是真正没有任何人与之建立联系的年轻男子。我们确实有一个社区数据库，所以顺便说一句，所有这些数据你都可以。免费下载、分析并进行研究。它已被研究人员、记者和政策制定者下载了数千次。
So our goal was to really get this out into the public for people to use it. So there's a whole community database where we track kind of location and community characteristics of things. Nothing has really jumped out yet. You know, it's one of those we can't exactly predict who's going to do this. We can't exactly predict where it's going to happen. but there's no real exact profile. It's kind of, it changes constantly, sort of with each shooting that occurs.
所以我们的目标真的是把这些公之于众，供人们使用。因此有一个完整的社区数据库，我们在其中追踪位置和社区特征等内容。目前还没有真正突出的结论。你知道，这是那种我们无法准确预测谁会做这件事的情况。我们也无法准确预测它会发生在哪个地方。但没有真正的精确剖面。它在不断变化，随着每起枪击事件的发生而持续改变。
Are there any other policy changes that you're advocating for that would really make a difference here? Yes, when our book, we came up with over 30 different potential prevention strategies. And we tried to organize it around things individuals can do, things institutions can do, and then things as a society that we need to do. And I think the society stuff is a heavier lift. And I think we get stuck there sometimes and we can feel paralyzed when the societal level stuff is not happening. But we do.
你还在倡导哪些其他政策改变，能够真正带来改变？是的，在我们的书中，我们提出了30多种不同的潜在预防策略。我们试图围绕个人可以做的事情、机构可以做的事情以及我们作为一个社会需要做的事情来进行组织。我认为社会层面的事情是一项更艰巨的任务。我认为我们有时会陷入其中，当社会层面的事情没有发生时，我们会感到瘫痪。但我们的确需要。
We need gun control laws. We need crisis response teams in schools. But then there's these things at the institutional level. So things like anonymous reporting systems or crisis response teams or training in crisis intervention and suicide prevention. or safe storage campaigns or teaching media literacy and social emotional learning. There's things we really can be doing that the data would say could have a difference. And then even at the individual level, some of my favorite stories are people we interviewed
我们需要枪支管制法律。我们需要学校里的危机应对团队。但随后还有机构层面的事情。比如匿名举报系统、危机应对团队、危机干预和自杀预防培训。或者安全存放宣传活动，或者教授媒体素养和社交情感学习。有些事情我们确实可以去做，数据表明这些事情会带来改变。然后即使在个人层面，我最喜欢的一些故事也是关于我们采访过的人，
who planned to do a mass shooting and change their mind. And when they changed their mind, and some of these were even men who were at the school with the gun in their backpack and changed their mind. and it tends to be a human connection, right? Somebody connecting with them, somebody getting him through the moment, somebody giving them a little bit of hope, somebody seeing them. One in particular, this man is a TED talk, Aaron Stark, but he talks about how he was planning on doing a mass shooting.
他们曾计划实施大规模枪击但改变了主意。当他们改变主意时——其中一些人甚至是在学校里、背包里藏着枪但改变了主意的男性——这往往归结于人类的某种连接，对吧？有人与他们建立连接，有人陪他们度过那个时刻，有人给予他们一丝希望，有人看见了他们。其中特别有一个人，这个人做过TED演讲，叫亚伦·斯塔克（Aaron Stark），他谈到自己曾计划实施大规模枪击。
And kind of the day before, he went over his friend's house, and his friend's mom had baked a pie because he was coming over. And sitting down and eating that pie, was, it stopped him from doing a mass shooting. Like it was that powerful of a moment that somebody would have thought, I'm going to make a pie in his honor. It was just a human connection. And so sometimes I think we can get so caught at what we need to do societally that we sometimes forget that we can all just be baking pies for each other. You never know when that connection is actually having a really meaningful moment for somebody.
就在前一天左右，他去了朋友家，朋友的妈妈因为他要来烤了一个馅饼。坐下来吃那个馅饼，就是这件事，阻止了他去实施大规模枪击。这是一种如此强大的时刻，本以为会有人想：“我要为了他的荣誉烤个馅饼。”这只是一种人与人之间的连接。因此，有时我认为我们太纠结于我们在社会层面上需要做什么，以至于有时忘记了我们其实都可以为彼此烤馅饼。你永远不知道这种连接什么时候会真正对某人产生非常有意义的影响。
And you have interviewed a number of mass shooters personally, right? I mean, how did you go about that? How did you find them and convince them to talk to you? Why would they talk to you? Yeah. So before I went to graduate school, before I was an academic, I worked with men facing the death penalty as an investigator, and I developed their cycle, social life histories for their sentencing hearings.
你曾亲自采访过几位大规模枪击者，对吧？我的意思是，你是怎么做到的？你是如何找到他们并说服他们跟你谈话的？他们为什么会跟你谈话？是的。所以在上研究生之前，在我成为学者之前，我作为一名调查员与面临死刑的男性合作过，我为他们的量刑听证会撰写了他们的社会心理生平史。
And so to me, it wasn't that big of a stretch to just say, well, let's just go talk to them, right? Like, let's go ask them why they did it. And people looked at me like I was out of my mind. But we, I just wrote a letter to every living perpetrator I could find who was incarcerated, incarcerated for life. Most of them die in the act like we talked about. Most of them either killed themselves or are killed. So we identified, I want to say, 32 maybe, who were a living. I sent just, you know, letters, cold letters saying that I was a researcher and I wanted to talk to them. I didn't want to talk about their crime. I only wanted to talk about the build up to the crime and what their life was like up to the
所以对我来说，只是去和他们谈谈并不是什么大跨越，对吧？就像，让我们去问问他们为什么要这样做。人们看我的眼神就像我疯了一样。但是，我只是给我能找到的每一个被监禁的、被判终身监禁的在世凶手写了一封信。正如我们所讨论的，他们大多在行动中死亡。他们大多要么自杀，要么被杀。所以我们确定了，我想说大约32名仍在世的凶手。我只是发出，你知道的，冷信，说我是一名研究人员，我想和他们谈谈。我不想谈论他们的罪行。我只想谈谈犯罪之前的积蓄过程，以及他们在犯罪之前的
crime. I said you weren't going to get paid. I would never use your name. You weren't going to get any fame or attention out of this. The goal of this project is to prevent mass shootings in the future. And I got, well, I got a number of responses. I got some attorneys who said they can't because they're in a piece. heels. I got two very angry kind of I hate psychologists. Don't contact me. But I got seven perpetrators
生活是什么样的。我说你不会得到报酬。我永远不会使用你的名字。你不会从中获得任何名誉或关注。这个项目的目标是预防未来的大规模枪击事件。我得到了，嗯，我得到了一些回应。我有几位律师说他们不能接受，因为他们正在上诉。我有两个非常愤怒的、类似于“我恨心理学家，别联系我”的回应。但我得到了七个凶手的回应，
who wrote back and said they wanted to be interviewed. And from those seven, I was able to talk to five. Now, that's not a huge sample. It's a small group. Yes. It's a very small group. When you compare it to there's only 30 something living, it's a little better. And of course, the ones who talk to me are not necessarily representative of all perpetrators. These are perpetrators who are invested in kind of telling their story, I guess, who have a lot of shame and regret, I would say, and are trying to in some way do something positive. And so the ones you spoke to expressed regret, they were sorry for what they had done. They did.
他们回信说他们想接受采访。从这七个人中，我得以和五个人交谈。现在，这并不是一个巨大的样本。这是一个小群体。是的。这是一个非常小的群体。当你把它与只有三十几个在世凶手的事实相比时，情况稍微好一点。当然，那些与我交谈的人并不一定代表所有凶手。这些凶手致力于讲述他们的故事，我想，他们内心有很多羞耻和懊悔，并且试图以某种方式做一些积极的事情。所以你交谈过的人表达了懊悔，他们为自己所做的事感到抱歉？他们确实表达了。
Some of them had been 20 years. You know, some of them had been a few years. And so I would say most of them did not really feel connected or recognize the self that did that, right? They felt kind of disconnected from it. And so we're able to reflect on it. So what are you working on now? Are there other research questions that you're hoping to be able to answer as you continue collecting this data? Yeah. So we're constantly revising and updating the database, and a lot of that is based on kind of users' feedback. So we will be putting out version six at the end of this year, include all of the mass shootings from 2022 and then also some new variables. So for example,
其中一些人已经过去20年了。你知道，有些已经过去几年了。所以我想说，他们大多数人并没有真正感到与实施那个行为的自我相连，也没有认出那个自我，对吧？他们感觉与它某种程度上脱节了。所以他们能够对此进行反思。那么你现在在做什么？随着你继续收集这些数据，你还有其他希望能够回答的研究问题吗？是的。所以我们一直在修订和更新数据库，这很大程度上是基于用户的反馈。因此，我们将在今年年底发布第六版，其中包括2022年的所有大规模枪击事件，以及一些新的变量。比如
the role of SSRI drugs got a lot of attention over the summer from some policymakers. So we went through and we coded who was taking an SSRI so we could kind of add data to that conversation. We had a number of people ask about height and weight of perpetrators with the impression that they're small. So we're adding that. I know. So we add things that people come up with. We just, our last version, added all of the ACEs, the adverse childhood experiences, scores, because people were interested in that. So we're constantly revising the database.
SSRI药物的作用在今年夏天引起了一些政策制定者的高度关注。因此，我们进行了梳理，记录了谁在服用SSRI，以便为这一讨论补充数据。许多人询问凶手的身高和体重，他们印象中凶手个子都很矮。所以我们把这些也加进去了。我知道。因此，我们会根据大家的想法添加内容。在我们最新的版本中，我们刚刚添加了所有的ACE，即童年逆境经历评分，因为大家对此很感兴趣。所以我们一直在不断完善数据库。
The other people have- I want to ask why just SSRIs? And what would they be taking these for? Because, I mean, they could be taking drugs for ADHD. I mean, there are a lot of drugs that young people could be taking. I don't know. I get a lot of emails from a lot of people who have a lot of ideas about what causes a mass shooting. And the one email I get more than anything else is SSRIs.
其他人——我想问为什么偏偏是SSRI？他们服用这些药物是为了什么？因为，我的意思是，他们可能在服用治疗多动症的药物。我的意思是，年轻人可能会服用很多种药物。我不知道。我收到了很多人的很多电子邮件，他们对造成大规模枪击的原因有很多想法。其中我收到最多的邮件就是关于SSRI的。
And I think it was Marjorie Taylor Green who brought it up. And it got, it kind of went a little bit viral on social media, this idea that it's specifically SSRIs. I will tell you, it's a very, very small proportion of perpetrators that are taking them. It's not that. But we just wanted to add that data point. I'm not sure exactly where that thinking comes from. But I get a lot of people have a lot of ideas about things that should be coding. The other big project we're working on right now is actually coding threats of school shootings.
而且我认为是玛乔丽·泰勒·格林（Marjorie Taylor Green）提出了这一点。这在社交媒体上有点走红，这种认为罪魁祸首专门是SSRI的观点。我可以告诉你，服用这类药物的凶手比例非常非常小。根本不是那么回事。但我们只是想把这个数据点加进去。我不确定这种想法到底是从哪里来的。但我发现很多人对应该记录哪些内容有很多想法。我们现在正在进行的另一个大项目其实是记录校园枪击威胁。
So threats are through the roof up like 300%. We've been tracking threats since 2018. And we finally are getting started coding all of them. So we're coding about 2,000 threats of school shootings and trying to look, for patterns in terms of how schools are responding, who's doing it, why they're doing it. I think we've now got a handle on who commits a school shooting. What we don't understand is who are these hundreds of kids a year threatening to do a school shooting and maybe they are joking or maybe they, you know, and we don't really have a
因此，威胁事件急剧增加，上升了约300%。我们从2018年开始追踪威胁事件。我们终于开始着手对所有这些威胁进行编码。所以我们正在对大约2000起校园枪击威胁进行编码，并试图寻找模式，看看学校是如何反应的、是谁在这样做、他们为什么这么做。我想我们现在已经大致了解了是什么样的人会实施校园枪击。我们不了解的是，每年这几百个威胁要进行校园枪击的孩子到底是谁，也许他们是在开玩笑，也许他们，你知道的，我们其实并没有
handle on what's going on there. Some kids are serving, you know, 10, 20 year prison sentences for something they posted on TikTok because we just don't have any good guidance about how. how we should be intervening here. What's the appropriate intervention? So that's what we're working on right now is trying to help schools figure out what to do here because I have principals will call me
掌握那里到底发生了什么。有些孩子因为在TikTok上发布的内容而面临10年、20年的监禁，因为我们对于该如何干预缺乏良好的指导。什么是适当的干预措施？这就是我们目前正在努力的方向，试图帮助学校弄清楚在这里该做些什么，因为会有校长打电话给我
and say somebody wrote something on the bathroom stall. Should I shut down the district? You know, and I don't know. These schools have no training and how to be making these decisions. So we're trying to add some data to that problem. Well, this is amazing information. I really appreciate you talking to me today
然后说有人在卫生间隔间里写了些东西。我是不是应该关闭整个学区？你知道的，我也不知道。这些学校在如何做出这些决定方面没有任何培训。所以我们正试图为这个问题增添一些数据。好吧，这些信息太棒了。非常感谢您今天与我交谈
and wish you the best of luck in this work, which is so important. Thank you, Dr. Peterson. Thank you so much. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.combeckycology.org or on Apple Stitcher or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you hear, leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
并祝您在这项极其重要的工作中一切顺利。谢谢你，彼得森博士。非常感谢。您可以在我们的网站 www.apa.org/research/action/speaking-of-psychology 上，或者在 Apple、Stitcher 以及您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学聊天》往期的节目。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org 与我们联系。
Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyin. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学聊天》由李·温厄曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·孔丁（Chris Kondyin）。谢谢收听。我是美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。